1988 in Czechoslovakia formerly known as
the Czechoslovak social Republic is
getting a bit Restless its leader was
first secretary of the Communist Party
me logic s who famously led the purges
of the 1970s you cash in the Communist
Party were very much in control of
Czechoslovakia at this point and weren't
suffering from a great deal of dissent
as was the case in say Poland or East
Germany quality of life there was
slightly higher than the rest of Eastern
Europe and the markers of modern life
like television were widely available
which along with all of the mass media
was tightly controlled by the government
this prevented notable dissidents such
as Vaart Slav who fell from reaching an
audience this isn't to say that the
people of Czechoslovakia didn't have any
complaint many especially the young had
a great deal throughout 1988 in 1989
there were demonstrations throughout the
country notably in Bratislava as well as
in the capital Prague these were merely
calls for reforms though and weren't
revolutionary in nature and so the
government did little about them in fact
the communist government had seen what
was going on throughout the Eastern Bloc
and so made some superficial concessions
to make it look like they were willing
to reform on the 17th of November 1989 a
student demonstration took place in
Prague to commemorate the murder of a
student by the Nazis 50 years earlier
many of these students then started
chanting anti-communist slogans which
led to the police dispersing the
protesters rumours spread that a student
had been killed by the police and for
many this was the final straw
tens of thousands then took to the
streets strikes were called in her Vell
along with other noted anti-communist
made their way to the Capitol in what is
known as The Velvet Revolution strike
spread protests grew in UK along with
the entire communist government resigned
on the 24th of November he was replaced
by Karel Urbanek who was a much more
moderate communist but by this point
many people were simply sick and tired
of the broader regime an urban a class
it for a whole five days he did however
in the communist party's monopoly on
power before resigning after several
weeks of negotiations a compromise
government was established which for the
first time since 1948 was majority
non-communist Havel was made president
of Czechoslovakia by this government on
the 28th December and soon after this he
gave a blanket pardon to all of
Czechoslovakia is political prisoners
minor reforms were undertaken but the
process of formally ending communism and
transitioning to a capitalist model
needed to wait for this new government
to gain legitimacy this was done via
elections in June of 1990 we saw have L
retained the presidency central
parliamentary elections were vows
the Civic Forum win which then ruled
alongside its Slovak equivalent the
public against violence party the
separation of the anti communist bloc
into Czech and Slovak parts is
indicative of a brand new problem that
Czechoslovakia now faced the resurgence
of nationalism which communism had
previously suppressed this doesn't mean
that this nationalism couldn't be dealt
with the majority of Czech and Slovak
citizens along with their politicians
were in favor of maintaining the
Czechoslovakian union a new election in
June 1992 saw two new frontrunners the
Civic Democratic Party led by vat Slav
Klaus and the movement for a democratic
Slovakia led by Vladimir metzia amid
1992 Klaus and Metz er sat down to
discuss what the new Czechoslovakia
would look like and they couldn't agree
on anything
Mitsy I wanted the slovak half of the
country to have its own currency and
more autonomy than the Czechs wanted to
give it you should be aware that met
CEA's demands were largely his own and
that slovak politicians would have been
quite happy to simply approve of a union
of equals instead he made it clear that
the Czechs didn't really care and so it
was better for them to both go their own
ways the Slovak National Assembly voted
in mid-july to create a new constitution
and a fancy new flag for their new
country the Slovak Republic it was
agreed that Czechoslovakia would divide
on January the 1st 1993 the Slovak
Republic in the Czech Republic thus went
their own ways in what is called The
Velvet divorce few people in either
country were really that upset about the
break-up
barring Havel but no one listened to him
anymore but also few were happy about it
the breakup of Czechoslovakia is
interesting not simply because it gave
the world two new nations but because
it's one of the only national
disillusions which came about on a tide
of apathy I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching and a
special thanks to all of these patrons
you see on screen for their generosity
in supporting the show and a
particularly special thanks to James
Bissonnette party Boyko Michael Reynolds
Gustav Swan Winston Cawood Skye Chappell
Adam Harvey Gable airy and azekah flash
you